Hello everybody. Hope that you're good.
It's been a long time with other YouTube
videos, but they are back. Uh I've been
traveling, enjoying moving house. So,
it's been a process. You know, the the
last time I uploaded a video was I think
in March or April. I remember we were
here uh 80K and the last video was only
about you know, we should buy the the
weekly 50 MA potentially. The bottom is
here because we are you know filling
this long week in the weekly time frame.
We are testing the bull market support
which is the weekly 50 MA. You can see
that every time we come to the weekly 50
MA we see bounces okay in all the bull
markets. So we were saying buy the
weekly 50 MA support. Okay, expect a
bounce then from 80K and we did we saw a
60% pump all the way to 120K and now by
coincidence we are in a similar
situation. We're very close to the
weekly 50 MA. Okay, the weekly 50 MA
right now is above 101K. So it's in look
in top left corner 101,147.
That's the weekly 50 MA and we're
already at 107K. Okay. So, we're going
to talk about this weekly 50 mA. But
first, let's go into the 4 hours time
frame. Uh, I don't know if you all read
the Bitcoin update that I posted
yesterday. But basically, what I was
saying is that, you know, we are in a
high time frame uptrend. You can see
that by looking at the weekly time
frame. This is clearly a high time frame
uptrend. we are inside a correction
within that high time frame uptrend
potentially could go all the way to the
weekly 50 MA like we saw in previous
times and in low time frame I was saying
that I don't see a very clear direction
so it makes me think that this is some
kind of a of a range okay and you could
draw your range lows in this orange line
I'm pulling them lower Um what I'm
thinking here is that it's possible that
if we drop below this orange line, there
is a lot of space to continue going
lower all the way to 101k, you know,
102K
um potentially filling the 100% of this
week. Okay. Yes, you're going to tell me
this week is only on Binance, but it's
not. It's not in Binance. Only it's in
Binance. It's in by bit. It's in
bluffing. It's in B X in Bet.
Okay. Okay, the only chart that doesn't
have this week is Coinbase chart. So,
we're going to consider that in terms of
liquidity, this week is real. Okay, so
yeah, it could get 100% filled. You
already got at least 50% and you guys
know that with my week fill strategy,
all I say is that long weeks need to get
filled at least 50%. Once they get
filled 50% or more, we can consider them
as completed. price doesn't need to go
to the 100%. Now, however, if price
comes back to around the 50% level and
there is no a bounce. So, for example,
here you can see that we filled the 50%
at least price bounce. Well, okay,
perfect. But then it couldn't break this
high, this local high. it got rejected
and now we are again around that same
level around the 50%
level of that week which makes it more
likely that I continues dropping to the
100% of the week. Okay, that's what I
usually see in the week strategy. So
that's a sign of caution to me. That's
what I've been saying yesterday in the
Bitcoin soon update. And I would say
that if we drop below this orange line,
then it will be very likely that price
drops lower to the 100% of the week
fill. You can see there a beautiful
deviation below the range lows because
there you also have the weekly 50 MA
that it's a big support where we would
expect a good reaction, an aggressive
bounce. So in terms of high time frame,
I'm still bullish. I'm going with a
trend 101k. If we get there, there
should be a bounce. So that's the most
likely scenario. And in low time frame,
I consider this to potentially be a
range and potentially head towards the
range lows. Okay. Now,
also I support this theory that we are
still in a bull market. I I know that
some of you might disagree and that's
fine. I'm only telling you my theory. So
some of you might criticize it. That's
fine. That's what is what it's about.
But you know, you have the Fed injecting
liquidity. Now you also have the US
government shut down. When he reopens,
they have to pay bills. They have to
inject more liquidity. Then then you
also have the companies of the S&P 500
doing very good earnings. Okay?
Especially at by the end of Q3 and now
the first month in October of Q4,
they've been doing good earnings. So
during it's going well I would say you
know it's likely that with all this
liquidity getting injected into the
market prices should move on especially
when Bitcoin is delayed is is behind the
global monetary supply okay and all
these liquidity injections. So yeah, I
would say that it's very likely that we
are still going to go higher. Okay. So
yeah, in my opinion, it's more likely
that we continue going higher and if we
go to 101K that there is a bounce. Now,
right now, I'm flat. I'm I'm I'm not in
a trade because I don't see things very
clear. Okay, I'm waiting to see what
happens. I suggested the telegram
channel which is free and I recommend
you guys to join because I'm way more
active there than on than on X. So I'll
leave you the link in the description. I
was saying that I'm expecting and this
is pure instinct. I don't have any info
of course you know I'm just an analyst
in my from my house but I was saying
that this week there could be news
either from Donald Trump or from the
Federal Reserve of the US. um that that
could move the market. So um you usually
when I see price, you know, so uncertain
that doesn't move much. It's kind of
waiting for something, you know, and
yeah, many times the chart or most times
or almost pretty much always the chart
is ahead of the news. And when it's like
this is because something is probably
going to happen. Okay, potentially is
more likely in my opinion that this news
or whatever happens triggers a move down
like this. Okay, and that's what I'll be
looking to get into a position. All
right, so that's what I'm kind of
expecting for Bitcoin. Uh if you want an
excuse then you can go to the TGR bonds
and it's true that it's likely that
price you know that probably formed a
bottom over here. Looks to me like a
bottom
formation here. Okay. And now price is
potentially going to go to 420 or 433.
Okay. As you can see two resistances.
So that could be the excuse, but let's
see. All right. You know that when the
10year
deal goes up, it puts pressure on the
S&P. The S&P, if you go to the S&P 500,
you can see that yeah, the chart is very
bullish,
but it's normal that it do some retests.
But for example, here
you could say that this could be a good
support. Okay, same as for example it
was here that you could see the same.
Okay, in there and you can see how you
know price broke this resistance went up
tested back this support. Okay, went up
and now price could go back here to test
the support to continue going higher.
Okay, so something like that is what I'm
expecting. Still I do think that we are
in a high time frame uptrend but I'm
cautious in low time frame. More things
Ethereum
4 hours time frame. Let's have a look. I
searched Ethereum and Solana charts last
night on Telegram to complete the
Bitcoin update with some alcoins. What I
was saying is that you know I see a lot
of liquidity in Ethereum below this line
because if you notice now it's been now
it's starting to take that liquidity.
You can see here hang on sorry excuse me
you can see here one two three four hits
there to the downside. A lot of
liquidity if you imagine in all this
area here. Okay, a lot of liquidity here
that is full of liquidity, full of stop-
losses. And you can see how price has
started today going there. Okay, now I'm
expecting it to go a bit lower at least
to this below below this low here where
it could take all the liquidity. Then
from there maybe we see a reaction
acceptance above the range lows again
could be a safe entry. If you are more
aggressive then you can just place some
buy limit orders below this low you know
expecting that that will be a just a
liquidity wrap to continue pushing price
higher and sparing around 40 50% of the
position
to spare those orders here. Okay. So for
example you could enter here 50% and
here 50 50. That's just some ideas you
could take and this one would be around
the 100% of the week fill. Okay, so just
some ideas. Same for Solana. Sena is
already doing the move. I I notice the
same. Look at this trend line, guys.
Don't you think that most traders that
they go to the bookshop and just buy the
first trading book they see because they
are pretty much all the same except the
ones that talk about trading psychology.
Respect for those ones. But the ones
that talk about technical analysis,
they're pretty much telling you follow
the trend, right? So if you see a trend
line like this, what you're going to be
doing is you're going to continue
longing every touch of that trend line.
Okay? Now eventually in reality what we
see is that you know after three four
hits if price goes back to the trend
line the most likely is that it breaks
through it breaks down much lower to hit
or lose a stop loss. So any trader that
was opening new longs here gets
immediately stopped. Okay? And for
example, you think this guy here took
profits here. Most traders didn't. Most
traders are holding that trade towards
this area here. Okay. So, those guys are
also going to get stopped. That's
already what happened. Price is going
lower. Now, I don't I'm not sure how low
Solana will go because I was expecting
that, you know, if Bitcoin goes to 101K,
if Ethereum goes to 3,600, 3,500,
then Solana could go to 170, but
so far it's taking a bigger hit. So,
yes, it could go lower than what it's
market in the chart. So, my take on
Solana would be or this is what I'm
doing. I'm trading with caution this
week because I see it very uncertain.
All I'm doing is waiting. Waiting for
the news to happen.
Waiting for Bitcoin to make the move
that we've talked here. If this happens
and once Bitcoin is ready for a bounce,
once Bitcoin is in this area, then I'll
go and go back to Solana. Okay, maybe
Solana is here or maybe Solana is here
or maybe it's here. I don't know. And
that is where I can start to look for
longs in Solana, not sooner because
Solana is going to follow Bitcoin. Okay,
just so you understand a bit the
priorities. So that's pretty much
everything, guys. I hope that this video
was helpful. And
I don't know if you guys missed the
videos, but I I did. I think it's fun.
So I probably see you again this week.
Okay. Thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you soon.